i don't know if you guys read um the
four hour work week but tim ferriss
basically opens that narrative you know
with the story that you know he he got
into what he got into by basically
volunteering at non-profits in silicon
valley sleeping in his mom's minivan um
i don't even think he took a paycheck
you know to begin with so it's like you
know just just putting yourself in rooms
where there's legends is a is a good way
to start um you know the stuff that jay
talks about with you know successful
people not wanting to mentor
people that are unsuccessful or unknown
um
you've got to be careful with that
because um
some of these guys really value their
time and quite often what the what
they'll end up hearing and i'm sure all
of you have heard this at some point
where somebody will message you or dm
you and it's like hey here's my problem
i want to pick your brain
and you're okay with doing that until it
happens like 200 times
right or 20 times you know at some point
you're like okay whoa whoa whoa i've
i've got to protect my time and i have
to put some sort of like filter in place
so
when you find that happens as a guy
that's a few notches down on the totem
pole and you're trying to level yourself
up and get yourself in those other
network rooms it's really important to
lead with value like don't just show up
and be like hey guys here's my problems
and just barf it all up everywhere show
up with some value and try to try to add
something to their business their their
community their lives before you try to
take because what a lot of really
successful people here when they hear
hey i want to pick your brain is it here
i want to steal your time and pick and
pick your wallet right
yeah i i think that's a really good
point and that's one of the reasons why
we started doing meetup groups in our
radio show and all other stuff hey i
want to pick your brain call a radio
show right or show up to the meetup
group that's exactly what i do because i
get dms now jay and i'm like you know
what you've got two options you can
either book me for private coaching or
call in on my unplugged alpha show right
because it because it gives me content
it also gives them an opportunity to
talk to me for free too right yeah and
it's like you there's all these
different ways for well no i want to
have a sit down i get a i'm sure you get
a million more than i do but i get it
all the time instagram facebook and then
email hey i need you to call me i'm like
what are we what are we going to talk
about
yeah i'm like we need to talk about x y
and z well here's we do 30 events a
month now it's kind of now i'm not at
all those i'm not most of them but we do
30 events a month and we do a radio show
every day like you can just
call in send an email talk about on the
show right and then if they don't if
they can't now this is where it gets
interesting rich
and i'd love to get y'all's take on this
if they can't follow those directions on
on how can i put this they can't follow
the directions on where i want to apply
my value then i know we're not going to
be doing business together like this
absolutely yeah it's not going to work
yeah yeah absolutely dude it's a total
filter like i'll say call in on my tua
show stands for the unplugged alpha you
know you can see i mean i can see it on
my stream yard thing number number 21.
and then when they say something like
what's that or when's the show it's like
really like you're just some [ __ ]
troll you know sitting around on some
social media platform randomly messaging
strangers you don't know for advice on
your dumb choices in life like you
haven't actually watched any of my
freaking content
i love it when rich goes did you read my
book and these guys are always like
no
but that's the big lesson and takeaway
is that no matter what level you're at
if you're trying to like level up you
have to pay to play and it's not
necessarily like with you know money
sometimes yeah it is money but other
times it's with time it's with research
it's with putting in the work but
there's no such thing as the free lunch
and like you you have to pay to play so
right if you want to get in the room
with rich either hey sign up and all
right let me see if you got skin in the
game or about it or hey
you said you read my book all right tell
me what's in you know chapter 10. okay
good you've done your homework so you
got to provide some type of value but
there's always a price and so if you
think that you can kind of skirt by and
you know get the most out of things
without like having to pay some type of
toll it's like no it's just the
fundamental rule of the universe like
you gotta pay to play
yeah so i mean
josh is a cool guy like i met up with
him in la a few years ago when i did a
bit of a trip with my um kiddo and it's
like you know the guy's connected like
he knows everybody at the high end
exotic car dealerships he knows the
restaurants to go to he knows the roads
like he's got the connection so how did
you build up that network in you know
that area of your life like how did that
work out for you how'd you do that
because not everybody starts like that
right oh yeah i mean i definitely did
not start off uh like that whatsoever um
but it kind of goes back to i think uh
50 shades of set at best it's really
about business game right and so all the
aspects of principles that you take from
game you want to apply it in a business
sense and like such things as spinning
plates for example is a very very
critical um component to it but the way
i always treat things is that you know
people ask me what do i do because i'm a
consultant and i tell people you know
i'm just a guy that
is the middleman between people with
problems and people with solutions and
that's really what it is so in business
professionally i do that i get large
checks for it it's nice but also in the
social scene the social circles right so
if you need a restaurant recommendation
in the car world that's where i really
got my start was out in the car scene
because i'm a huge car guy um and so you
know now i'm so well connected like
whenever anyone hits me up for a car i
ask okay well what do you want to get
you literally anything from a toyota
corolla on the simple side to an
allocation for bugatti because there's
only about 40
allocations left so if you want one let
me know and anything in between that
spectrum but it goes by adding a lot of
value and again just recognizing where
you can start being a bit of a
matchmaker right where you can pair up
different people that have different
interests and different insights so a
good example of this was i was up in
monterey for car week i mean i got um my
invite to the bentley the hospitality
villa so i'm there there's a very nice
elaborate display of mcallen and so you
know you're at a very well to do event
when mcallen was listening to macallan
12 or mcallen 25 sorry which is about
2500 bucks a bottle starting that was
the cheap stuff that they were just
using to make cocktails with
so you know we're there we're talking a
befriend this uh one guy just you know
started talking just asking like hey man
you know meet some interesting people
just regular genuine conversation right
and so the next thing you know he's
pouring me some of this macallan m black
which comes in this crystal bottle and
so it turns out it's like about 10 grand
for a bottle of this stuff and it i mean
it is phenomenal definitely phenomenal
but it's like okay you happen to be down
in my neck of the woods okay we'll let's
let's make something happen let's keep
in touch so
you know a couple weeks go by i get an
email from him saying hey i'm doing this
little private tasting but i've got a
charity fundraiser right where i'm
trying to
um
he's going to do like a 5k and raise
some money so if you want to come to
this event mike's going to be like 100
bucks a person so my doctor i got you
know i'll take my mom to get a couple
friends out um so you know dude
charitable donation have a great little
time it's a good little event i could
have been cheap and like well i mean i
want to pay like a hundred bucks for it
but it's like no you know what he's a
genuine guy he's got something that he
is really important to him all right
let's begin see how we can make our
mutual interest um line up or just at
the very core of it right just come from
a genuine place of hey i think he's a
cool dude and we're gonna do something
fun so we're gonna do the event we have
a good time turns out my his wife is a
big choreographer for a lot of dance
groups and one of my business partners
he's actually launched a new cirque du
soleil type show
down here in l.a so it's like hey you
know what
you guys should come out
and enjoy the show it'll be on me i can
get you guys comp tickets everything to
be set up because i'm already going to
buy a couple tables anyway to support my
friends and that's another thing that
you want to do right with your friends
and your business partners if they have
events where they have businesses you
want to be an active investor whether
you're helping them promote on social
media whether you're
supporting them financially there's a
lot of different things that you can do
and so again it's about providing that
value and pairing up like people so they
the folks in the county they came out
they had a great fantastic time and then
the next thing i know i'm getting
invited to this very very high-end
dinner
at one of the most high-end restaurants
in los angeles so we're being wined and
dying and turns out they're releasing a
brand new bottle uh our new expression
of mcallen which isn't due out for
another couple months and then the next
thing i know i'm wind up with two
bottles of this unreleased mcallen
before the market even gets it as a
thank you for showing up and it's all
because i recognize hey this guy's a
cool guy he has an interest in this this
would be a fun thing for them to do so
again just pairing it up but the biggest
thing i have to say is just you got to
be authentic about it like if you are
not authentically vibing or getting
along with people um i think it was warm
but he said it best he said
i will it doesn't matter what business
i'm in as long as i like the people i'm
working with then we can always do
business together so you got to be
genuinely authentic but you also again
have to be
make those investments right so if i
didn't spend the three hundred dollars
there i'm not getting a bottle of you
know well he's probably give me at least
like three grand in alcohol already just
comp um but you know again it's all
these little things that you these
little investments that you make and
they can yield so many large returns and
the other side of the equation too is if
you have guys that are coming up
and guys that are trying to really pick
your brand and understand become kind of
like your sort of mentees right like
treat them right like one of my business
partners who's a very very sharp very
smart guy
been the navy for a while got out
he came up to car week with me um and he
was kind of on the fence about like
coming down to hang out to la to take
care of to see some of these folks who
are working on this mutual project
together just because he had a couple
things and obligations back home where
he lives in hawaii so i told him hey man
i will pay for your hotel
come down
we're gonna have a good time right so
pay for the hotel for a couple days
um you know pick up in the lamborghini
on the first day going around blasting
the canyons having fun getting lunch go
out hang out with some girls have some
dinner uh then the second day we go we
actually meet our team um we get a lot
more production out of him because of
his head space of where he's at so it's
when you get you make these investments
in people you're gonna see the amount of
returns that you're gonna get and it's
also two right like by showing him such
a great time
the guy will go to war for me right if i
say hey let's go rob a bank over here
all he's gonna say is all right what
time and what caliber bullet do you need
right so that's how you also build and
um gather that sense of loyalty and you
really can foster kind of your own
private army and again when when you're
coming from that authentic mutual value
exchange
guys are going to start throwing stuff
at you that you would never even see
coming whether it's investments whether
it's events whether it's opportunities
it's
come from a very authentic place and
really so yeah a lot of it is really
just come from an authentic place and
again make those investments whether
it's in the people that you're trying to
reach and get access to or the people
that are trying to get access to you and
that you
really have a good sense of better on
the come up
you